Boyd:
Hi, my name's Ryan Boyd
and this is
Jonathan Terleski.
I am an engineer in our
developer relations group
working on OpenSocial
and Google Friend Connect,
and Jonathan
is the lead designer
on Google Friend Connect.
We're here today to talk
about Friend Connect Gadgets,
both design and implementation
of the code.
And if you have
any questions that come up
during the talk,
feel free to submit them
to the URL that you see
at the bottom there.
It's
tinyurl.com/gfc-questions.
And that's Google Moderator,
and we'll go
through those questions
at the end of the session.
At that time,
you also have the option
to come up to the microphone
and ask any additional questions
in person
if that's what you prefer.
Okay, so getting a little bit
into the agenda
and how we're gonna
spend our time here today.
But first,
why are you all here?
There are 5 million sites
around this world
which have Google
Friend Connect on them.
This is everything from
traditional content sites,
to big, major web sites,
to blogs.
So keep that in mind--
there's this huge audience
for any gadgets that you develop
for Google Friend Connect.
Those sites are also
very quickly growing.
100,000 new people join
those sites every single day.
So not only is your audience
pretty huge,
but it's growing as well.
So here's the agenda.
We're gonna start off with
a little bit of an introduction
to Friend Connect
for those of you that aren't
very familiar with it.
And then we're gonna go into
some of the things
around design
and who you're building for
and what types
of things to build.
And then we're gonna go back
and talk a little bit
about the code
and the differences between
building Google
Friend Connect gadgets
and building gadgets
for other platforms.
And lastly,
we're gonna end up
with the question and answers
that I talked about.
So introduction
to Google Friend Connect.
Google Friend Connect--
the reason it was created
was to allow you to instantly
awaken and strengthen
the communities
on your site.
Basically what this means
is out of the box
you can take
some copy and paste code--
like Vic demo-ed in the keynote
with the elements--
to a little bit more advanced
copy and paste code
with Google Friend Connect,
and plug that
into your web site
and instantly
allow people to log in
using the identities
of their choice
done through
the OpenID protocol
and also bring
their friends with them
from social networks
that support OpenSocial.
So after they're there and
they bring their friends in,
they can then interact
with other members of the site,
make new friendships,
and then send
their activities on that site
else--out elsewhere
on the web.
So here's a little bit
of a demonstration
of Google Friend Connect.
Two-minute run-through:
this is the Earth Hour web site.
This was for the Earth Hour
which happened
a little bit ago.
The idea is everyone
shuts off their life--
lights for an hour.
And we visited this site.
We go and say
we're gonna log in.
We can choose from a number
of different providers
or choose in OpenID.
So since this is
Google I/O,
I'm demonstrating with
my Google account here.
And I'm logging in.
And after I log in,
you can see I'm using
my Twitter profile--
the little icon
at the bottom there.
But I can go here
and choose to use
in the advanced options
any other profile that
I've linked up to this account,
which includes a variety
of social networks
listed at the bottom there.
I can also make
my activities on this site
published elsewhere
on the web--
other social networks
that support this
as well as other
Google Friend Connect sites.
Now you can see
a list of all the members
and my friends
from those other networks
and a friend request
up at the top there.
I can click on
any of the people
and find more information out
about their profile,
what other sites
they're members of,
who their friends are.
And after I do that,
I can go over here
and invite new people
to come join the site.
I can invite friends
from a variety
of different social networks--
Google, Orkut, Plaxo here
that I have linked up to.
And I can also invite people
from a number
of other different services.
So we're gonna go
back here to Google
and click on
the user Canoe
and write him
a short little note.
This message is customizable
by the app developer
in a more advanced
integration,
but here I'm just inviting him
to join the site
and come support the earth.
I send the invitation
and go back to the site.
And hopefully
he comes and joins.
But now I'm going to share
my thoughts to the world
and tell everyone
how much I love the earth,
and they should all
participate next year
in Earth Hour.
Gonna do that, and then I will
hit "Post" here in a second
after I type
my long-winded message.
And you can see my message
is available
for everyone on the site
to see.
Also, if you clicked
on my profile,
you can see at the bottom--
my activities,
and it says that I posted
that message on this site.
And not only is that viewable
on my profile here,
but in all other
of the 5 million
Google Friend Connect
enabled web sites.
Now, this demonstration
is primarily using
an out-of-the-box integration
of Google Friend Connect.
You can also do a little bit
of a deeper integration
with Google Friend Connect.
You notice here nothing really
looks like gadgets per se.
This is the Chow Down
example web site
that you can find linked off
of code.google.com.
And what it is is basically
a restaurant directory
that then I can click
on a restaurant and bookmark it,
and invite my friends out.
And it all uses
the REST and RPC APIs
to do
that sort of integration.
There's another session
tomorrow, I believe,
on Google Friend Connect
and deep integration
run by Arne Roomann-Kurrik
that you guys
should all go to
if you're interested in that
side of Google Friend Connect.
So with the deep integration,
you can integrate
directly into the flows
of your application,
directly into
the existing login systems.
But today we're here
to talk about
Google Friend Connect gadgets.
And social gadgets
with Google Friend Connect
basically allow you to create
some modular functionality
that you can install
on your own site
but can also be used
by many other of those
5 million web sites
around the world that have
Google Friend Connect on them.
So think about ideas
about modular functionality,
and Jonathan's going to
give you some frameworks
for doing
that thought process soon.
But first let's demonstrate
a couple gadgets here.
This is a poll gadget done
by a third party developer,
Alex.
And basically
I'm going through here
and voting on a--
what smartphone I use,
and then going through
and voting
on my favorite
programming languages.
And I click "Vote,"
and after I vote
I can see all the different
votes that were taken.
I can actually--
I don't demonstrate this here,
but I can actually
click on one of those
and see the pictures
of all the people
that have voted for,
you know,
say, Python
as their favorite language
if I wanted to establish
a relationship with them.
So this is a gadget.
This is also a gadget.
This is a gadget
developed by Google,
its Events Gadgets.
This web site
basically represents
a...advertisement
for a concert.
And on the side
is the Events Gadget
where you indicate
whether or not
you're interested
in attending that concert.
And you can see pictures
of all the people
that are attending
and that sort of thing.
You can see this gadget
is pretty deeply integrated
into the web site.
So you could have everything
from things that look like,
you know, modular boxes
that anyone can
plug into their site
or you can have things that
are really deeply integrated
but are still gadgets
and use things like skinning,
which we'll talk about
here later,
to make the look
and feel of the gadget
be very similar to the look
and feel of the web site.
Jonathan?
Terleski:
Um...
[laughter]
[applause]
Hi. My name's Jonathan.
I'm going to be talking
about some of the opportunities
and challenges
for designing for Google--
gadgets for
Google Friend Connect.
So while I'll be
talking specifically
about Friend Connect gadgets,
there's also, you know,
obviously implications
for designing OpenSocial
gadgets and stuff like that.
So to start off, I think
what you really need to do
is you need to come up
with an idea that makes sense--
and, you know,
a good idea that makes sense
in the frame
of Google Friend Connect.
So I want to start out
with a little bit of metaphor
just to kind of get, you know,
your minds in the right places.
So let's start off
with a pitch black room.
You know, nobody
can see each other.
You know, no one has any idea
that anyone else is there.
People are just toiling away
doing their own thing.
Sounds like a few web sites,
you know,
that I've visited.
So if we take that room
and we...
throw the Google Friend Connect
Members gadget on it,
we basically are turning
the lights on in that room.
Right? We're letting people
start to look around,
see each other.
You know, they can, you know,
walk up to somebody,
you know...
they can't really
do much yet.
And so that's where you
as, you know, developers
creating
Google Friend Connect gadgets,
you really come in,
right?
So...
gadgets are really out there
to help members
start to communicate
with one another
on the site.
With--without the gadgets
that we create,
without the gadgets
that you'll create,
you know, there's not
a whole lot that--
of functionality
we're offering.
So on the left
we have our comments gadget,
which just basically
enables very simple discussion
between--
between site members.
On the right, we have
the recommendations gadget,
and what that does
is it just allows--
you basically put buttons
around content on your site.
So, like, in this example,
the buttons were on photos,
and members could click on
those recommendation buttons
to basically
recommend that content
to other visitors
of the site.
And then you put
this aggregation gadget,
like, on your home page
or something like that.
So that's a gadget
we developed.
And then in the middle
is a gadget
developed by
a third-party developer,
and it's a question
and answers gadget
that basically lets people
ask questions
and get answers from
other members on the site.
And so, again,
you know, fundamentally,
gadgets are enabling people
to communicate
with one another
on the site.
So now I want to talk
about some of the similarities
and differences
between Friend Connect
and a traditional network
or OpenSocial container.
You know, some of you here
might be currently developing
OpenSocial gadgets for...
for traditional containers
that are out there.
Friend Connect's
a little bit different
because--
because of two things.
The first thing's audience.
And so audience, you know,
while you still want
to pay attention to, you know--
the end user
ultimately is your goal--
you know, these guys.
There's a new audience
involved in Friend Connect
that if you're doing
a traditional...
OpenSocial gadget
you might not be aware of.
It's a very powerful audience.
And that's
the site administrator.
So people who, you know--
sites that come along
and decide to use
Friend Connect
are people who, you know,
get a Blogger blog
and want to use Friend Connect
gadgets on their Blogger blog.
This is the individual
who is ultimately
making the decision
to install the gadget
on their site.
So it's no longer
this kind of game
around, you know,
how many community members
can you get
to install this gadget,
'cause they're not the one
actually installing
the gadget anymore.
They're just coming to a site
that's offering functionality,
and that functionality
is functionality
that you happen
to be providing.
And that's very different
than needing to, like,
you know, virally spread
your app as much as possible.
Now, you do need to,
you know,
kind of get in front
of site administrators,
and so when you
do create a gadget--
and Ryan'll
talk about this later--
is you can list it
in the Friend Connect
Gadget Gallery.
And that's part of,
you know,
a site administrator's
core experience
when they sign up
for Friend Connect--
there's a gallery
that's in the admin site
that they can access
that will have
third-party gadgets in it.
And so the powerful part here
is that, you know,
a single administrator
can basically
take your gadget,
put it on their site,
and the distribution
of your gadget
can literally go from zero
to hundreds, thousands,
you know, millions,
whatever,
depending on
the traffic of their site.
But what that also means
is that the bar has been raised.
So, you know, your gadget
needs to be more relevant,
more reliable.
If somebody's gonna trust
to put this on, you know,
the home page
of their site
or on every news story
page on their site
if they want to put comments at
the bottom of all their stories
or something--some other
equivalent functionality...
a site owner
really needs to be, you know,
comfortable and confident
taking your gadget
and putting it alongside
their brand.
So it needs to look good and
it needs to fit into the site.
And, you know,
a way to think about it
is, you know, how can you
as gadget developers
really create assets
for these sites?
How can you be something
that site owners depend on?
You know, that's
a good position to be in
as a--as a software developer.
So--and as
I mentioned earlier,
because of this new audience,
you know,
there's that--
there's less need to, you know,
try and spread your app
virally between people
while Friend Connect
has that--
as he showed some
of the invite stuff
around inviting to sites--
and more need to just
communicate the value
to--to site administrators.
So again, you're ultimately
creating, you know,
an experience with
the end user, but, you know,
the site administrators
kind of hold the keys
to distribution.
And you really need
to be focusing on relevance.
So create something useful
that makes sense on a web site.
And I'll talk about that
a little bit more
in a minute.
And also focus
on reliability.
Like, if your gadget is,
you know,
down 10% of the time
and it doesn't load,
like, that's probably
not gonna be on many sites
for very long.
So one last point
about audience
before I kind of
go into my next point
is that really
Google Friend Connect
is about making
the web more social.
And so,
this is a huge opportunity,
I think, for you
as gadget developers
to really light up
these latent communities--
as Ryan mentioned--
that already exist on millions
of existing web sites.
And I think
the key thing to remember
is that some of these users
will be the same users
that you're used to seeing
on social networks,
but there's also gonna be
a lot of people
who, you know,
you've never seen before.
There's gonna be
people out there
that, you know, don't care
to join a social network,
haven't joined a social network
yet, you know,
don't like the idea
of social networks.
But, like, you know, everybody
likes to be social.
So you really--
I think there's the ability
to reach kind of
that broader audience here.
So the second big idea,
I think, to think about
is context.
You know, as I
just mentioned, right--
you're out there
on the web.
And it means that--
what that means
is that the context
for a gadget
is not a traditional
social network,
you know,
profile page anymore.
You're now in the sidebar
of a web site.
You're now at the bottom
of every, you know,
blog post on this site.
You're really in--
in, number one,
places that are
probably more visible,
but number two,
just places that are different.
So, you know, the...
things that kind of
worked in one context
might not work in--in this
Google Friend Connect context
and vice versa.
So let's talk about some
UI stuff really quick here.
I am a designer.
So this is a--
a screenshot
of the Google
Social Web Blog--
kind of simplified
a little bit,
but this is
the basic gist.
And so you see on the right
they've got the--
just the default skinned Google
Friend Connect Members gadget
embedded on there.
But let's say
that the site administrator
actually, you know,
really wanted a black--
black background
and white text.
And all of a sudden,
their web site looks like this.
So content on the left
kind of, you know...
looks a little bit drab
just 'cause I didn't do
a whole lot of hackery.
But the thing on--
the pointer notices that
that gadget really now
doesn't feel
like part of the site.
It's really standing out.
And that's kind of
not what you want.
That's gonna--
if there's no flexibility
in your gadget,
once I put this on here,
I might find the functionality
neat for a little while
but I'm just
gonna get used to it--
I'm gonna--
I'm gonna start to see it
as, like, kind of the wart
on my site, right?
And so, you know,
you can fix that
by, you know, adding
skinning to your gadget.
And this stuff--
this is stuff
that Ryan'll
talk about later.
But, you know, so this is what
an administrator might do.
So this is using
just our admin site.
You can change the--
the options, the colors on--
on our default gadgets
to kind of make it
feel a little bit more--
like, more part of the site.
This is also a good way
just to mention to--
if you are
creating a gadget,
and you really--
and you need to add skinning
and you want to add skinning,
take your gadget,
throw it onto a site
with a black background
and white text,
and that'll pretty much
tell you,
you know,
help you along the way
on what is--what's the stuff
on my gadget
that's not yet skinnable
and needs to be?
Because that will pretty much
make any element of your gadget
stand out in a bad way.
And so,
dropping it on this
and really figuring out,
"Oh, yeah,"
like, "I forgot to make
the border skinnable."
Like, "I need to do that."
Or, "The inner borders
aren't skinnable."
Like, "I need
to think about that."
And obviously
that's how we came a lot of--
across some
of our skinning options.
We added some
as we went on.
So, you know,
another thing
to...think about
with regard to context,
in addition to just the fact
that you're on the web site,
is that, you know,
existing applications
that some of you
may have written--
so if you have
written applications
for OpenSocial containers--
they might not make sense
out on the web.
So--or at least not
for all Friend Connect sites.
So, you know, I don't like
to pick on people
but, like, the zombie biting
app, for example.
You know, the--
you know.
The church that wants to add
Google Friend Connect
to their site
is not going to be interested
in the zombie biting app.
And probably
not a lot of sites
are going to be interested
in a zombie biting app
I think is my larger point.
There might be a few,
like the Halloween site--
that's gonna love it.
But you really have
to think about, like,
the context
that you're in now.
It's not...you know,
little apps that users
can just pick up
and play with
with their friends.
I mean, this is something
that's really gonna be
on the front of someone's--
someone's site.
And so you just need
to just keep that in mind.
So just to wrap up
this section
and to get into
some design stuff,
again, audience--
continue to focus on the user
and all else will follow.
But remember
that administrators,
you know,
are your distributors.
So be useful,
provide relevant functionality,
and be reliable.
And then context--
your application
is part
of someone else's site.
You need to think about,
again,
the skinning options.
I'll get a little bit into
size options in a minute.
But also think
about creating something
that, like,
lots of sites can use.
You know,
the good example
I think that Ryan
gave to me
was the example
of the real-time chat app
that maybe
didn't work so well
in a traditional
social network
because, you know,
the overlap of--
if I have, you know,
Jonathan's chat
and that's on my profile,
you know, the number of
people visiting my profile
at any one time
is probably small.
Probably me.
But the, you know,
the overlap
of if I put real-time chat
on, you know,
the front page of something
that's getting hundreds
of thousands of visitors a day--
or even thousands
or hundreds of visitors a day--
there's--there's at least
a higher chance
of there being overlap
and it being useful.
So just think about that.
All right.
Whoa.
I think that, you know,
once you have that good idea
that you need to give it
kind of the good UI
that it deserves.
And so my goal is
when you walk out of here
to basically have
the basic gadget--
the basic structure of gadget
as I see it,
and then also
just the tools to get started
thinking about,
if you have an idea,
how you might start
just sketching out
what that might look like.
And so we've created
a few gadgets ourselves,
and I have
some experience there,
so I just wanted
to kind of walk through
some of this stuff.
So, you know,
first you have,
you know,
the gadget itself.
Some of our gadgets
look like this.
But they can also
They can be wide.
And the point here
is just that
there is no default size.
So on traditional
social networks,
you'll often have a size
or set of sizes
for the profile view.
You know,
the size is whatever--
you know, IFRAME
or whatever div,
like, the administrator
dumps it into, right?
And so that
can be configurable through--
we offer configuration
options for that,
that you can expose
to the administrator
so you can adapt to that.
But you need to make sure
that you're kind of
building that into your app.
And so, you know,
a good example here
is the--
the comments gadget.
And so, you know, it works
well in this smaller size
and, you know, text expands
as you open it up.
Just stuff
you expect it to do.
But if I take
the comments gadget
and maybe, you know,
make some intentionally bad
design decisions--
you could see, like,
maybe you wanted to be
super descriptive
and we wanted to call it
the "Comments
& Conversations" gadget.
But, you know, that's
not gonna work in sidebars
that are less
than 200 pixels,
which is a lot of sidebars.
Or, you know,
if you look closely,
you can see--
it's hard to see up here,
but a lot of the comments
are actually getting cut off.
And maybe that's
because there was a div
that was floating
over on the right
that's now been brought over
and is overlapping
some of the text.
Down in the footer,
where we've got some navigation,
we also wanted to put
a big call to action
that says, "Leave a comment."
You know, again, now that
that size has come down,
that text is starting
to overlap and not look so nice.
So you really need
to think about
kind of how size--
what role size
is going to play in your app.
And I'll go into what I think
a good minimum size is,
but one thing
I want to mention first
is just that text
can often be the long pole.
So, you know,
the two examples here--
the title and the footer.
But if you're
going into a sidebar
that's going to be
160, 180, 200 pixels,
you really need
to be thinking about,
"Oh, can I actually
fit in navigation
and a call to action here?"
Can I fit in, you know,
all these, you know--
What's my longest case?
Like, when I navigate
into a collection
and I have previous,
and next,
and then I want to offer
some, you know,
navigation to get
back up the hierarchy--
like, are those
all going to fit?
And then think about
that for German
or think about that for--
if you want to localize, right,
like, double it.
So it's--it's not--
it's not an easy problem.
It's just something
to be aware of,
and I don't have
a super good answer for you
about how to avoid it,
except for to go through
the states of your app
and see, like--
what are the, you know,
what are those complex cases
that really might
load up an area
with either navigation or--
or something you might be
doing in your content area
of your app.
So I mentioned I'd give you
a good minimum size
to focus on.
This is kind of what I--
what I...
have been following
in most of my design.
And the reason is
is that most sidebars
kind of fit in here.
And designing any smaller
is really, really hard
and annoying.
And so, for example--
but it really matters,
I guess...
on the audience
that you're targeting.
So if you're targeting,
you know, bloggers
that use Blogger,
and you want them
to be people
that are going
to adopt your gadget,
well, there's a lot
of Blogger templates
that are 160-pixel-wide
sidebars.
And so you better make sure
that your gadget looks good
in those templates.
And the same goes
for any other thing.
Like, you know, WordPress
has sets of templates.
There's content kind of
management things
that a lot of sites use that--
to throw sites up
that have
a lot of standards.
I've found that, you know,
if you're designing, you know,
180 pixels is probably--
you're gonna hit
most people there.
But again, some of the blogs
go down to 160.
So let's talk about some
of the--some more structures.
So there's the header.
What I'm kind of showing here
is that, you know,
the header hopefully
should be optional.
What we're finding
as we go on
is that, you know,
a lot of sites
already have, you know,
systems in place
either in their--
I had mentioned templates
and Blogger
is one example.
But there's other web sites
that already have
systems for basically
blocking off their content
and presenting it.
And so you kind of
have to think about, you know,
making that--that header,
you know, toggleable.
So the--the takeaway
is not to put...
you know, mandatory
functionality up in your header
and to make that
basically toggleable
by the--
by the site administrator.
The next piece
is the footer
where we commonly
throw navigation.
And I think--
if there was something
I was going to recommend
as a principle
to stick to,
this would be one of them,
which is--
a lot of the gadgets
we've made
and I think
all of the gadgets
that we have seen
third-party developers make--
at least everyone I've seen--
have been putting navigation
down in the footer like this.
And I think it's something
that's worked really well
as far as
users can expect
that when they're
in the middle of a collection
that they can look down there
and go through
the navigation like that.
And so that's one--
one thing I would
be recommending.
So here's an example of--
I'm--maybe I was in--
I was looking
at the Members gadget
at was looking
at a set of my friends.
And maybe
I clicked in on that
and what I got was--
got to this collection,
so now I can page through it.
But you'll also
notice now
there's a link
to go back in there.
Because not only have I started
navigating hierarchically,
but now I'm paging
through a collection.
And if somebody
pages into a collection
five, six, seven pages deep,
do you really want
to have them--
have to have them page
all the way back out
to just get back
to the previous screen?
So you need
to start thinking about
how is the user--
how is the user navigating?
And then one piece
that isn't really, you know,
part of, I guess,
a gadget proper--
it's kind of the other view
of it--is the Canvas mode.
And it's
the same type of mode
if you're used to developing
OpenSocial gadgets
that you'll--
that you'll recognize.
It's basically
a larger view of a--
of a guaranteed
view size.
And so, kind of
the recommendation I have
is to basically take users
there when it makes sense.
So a good example is
you are, you know, an app
that does photo tagging.
And you have--
a user is trying to--
to tag photos,
and the site administrator
has graciously given you
160 pixels wide by, you know,
300 pixels tall,
and they're trying to tag
faces in a photo.
So you can either
give them, you know,
a 50x50 photo
and have them
try and tag faces--
which probably won't
be very successful,
'cause each face will be
about 6 pixels big--
or you can take them
off to Canvas mode,
where you might have
a larger view of that photo.
And then it will allow them
to work in that space,
and then when they're done,
you know, bring them back.
And so, again, when thinking
about Canvas mode,
thinking about using it
kind of as a place
to take people
when they really need
to kind of stretch their legs
and get a little bit deeper--
for the Members gadget,
for example, one thing we do
when you go into--
but Canvas mode is we, you know,
show the names of the members
next to the photo,
'cause we have
that extra space.
So if you're looking
for someone in particular,
you can--
you can get to that.
Cool.
So those are just some of the
basic structures of a gadget,
and now I just want to give you,
in closing here,
just a framework to kind of
maybe start thinking about,
you know, how--
how do I take the idea
that, you know, I have now--
I know the basic structure.
How do I actually start,
you know,
filling that content area
with stuff?
So...
I guess the framework
I want to present is this.
So if you think
about your gadget
as having kind of
three key components to it--
so you think about objects,
you think about
user contribution,
and think about
user consumption.
And I'll explain this
with some examples.
So first you start
with objects.
So this is the--
the comments gadget.
So the object
in our comments gadget
is the comment itself.
The user contribution
is kind of the posting UI
for--for the user to post--
for users to post a comment.
And then the consumption
is just, you know,
that collection of comments
that members can
page through to--to view.
The Members gadget--
the object is the member.
The user contribution
side of it
is the joining of the site,
the becoming a member
of that site,
adding yourself
to that collection.
And the user consumption
piece of it
is just that, you know,
viewing that collection,
paging through that collection.
And of course this
is an oversimplification.
Both of these gadgets do more.
You can reply
to individual comments
and those are different.
You can click on someone's
face, view their profile.
But again--
those are all objects
that have user contribution
pieces to them
and user consumption
pieces to them.
So just starting off,
thinking about,
"Okay, here's the idea I have
for my--
for my gadget."
And just starting to determine--
what are the objects?
How do I let users
contribute those?
How am I going
to display those to users?
And just start, you know,
kind of sketching that out
will be a big help in,
I think,
getting you on the road to
creating a really good gadget.
So one example that--
that I came up with that I like
is to show that
this kind of can apply
to things
that maybe just aren't,
you know, kind of
the gadgets we've made,
the comments gadgets,
stuff like that--
is let's imagine that you've
written an interactive game
where, you know,
the main...
the main interaction
the user has
is with
an interactive game itself--
not, you know,
something you're doing...
in the, or, sorry,
not--not in the gadget,
but it's with a game
where you're not
interacting with normal
kind of UI components,
that you're actually,
you know, you've got a custom UI
and stuff like that.
The stuff that comes out
of that game, right, are scores.
And so, I think about--
when you think about
a score object,
in that model that
I just was talking about,
you kind of get the--
the idea
that, you know, users
are generating these objects,
that they're--want to be able
to contribute to these objects,
that they want to be able to
share these with their friends,
other people on the site,
contribute it to our
leaderboard, whatever it is.
And then
the consumption side--
somebody's who's just
gotten the high score
wants to be able
to compare against other people
and see where they fall
kind of in the ranks.
And so just by thinking
about, you know,
that basic idea of, "Okay, what
are the objects in my game?"
You know, okay, well,
the score comes out at the end
when they die,
et cetera.
You know, you come up
with a concept of leaderboards,
and I think that's...
I don't--it was
interesting to me, I guess.
So figuring out kind of
what your base object will be,
how you're going
to display those objects,
and how users will
contribute to those objects
is really one of
the first things you should do
when trying to sketch out
your particular gadg--
the gadget you want to make.
So did the user
just draw a picture?
You know,
let 'em post it.
Did the user just make
a donation to that site?
Let them be featured
as the latest contributor.
It's not always
just taking what they took
and spitting it
right back at them.
You can take what they took,
mash it up
with other stuff,
do some other things to it,
and--or present it
back to them in a unique way
that's different that the way
they contributed it.
But, again,
thinking about
just those pieces
of, you know--
you get the--
kind of the nouns
and then you start
to get the verb for
"how did they give it to you,"
and the verb for "how do you
give it back to them"
by thinking about it
this way, I think.
And I think also
when you think about,
you know, kind of
each object or each action
in this framework,
you start to think about
each object or each action
as a potentially
shareable moment.
And I think, you know,
what this--
this helps you not only
get a better idea
of what your gadget
should be about,
but it helps just make
your gadget more social
because of that.
You're always thinking about,
"Oh, what are users
creating in my gadget?"
"Oh, what could users
potentially consume
that other users
are creating?"
And so you really start to,
I think--
social features
start to pop out
kind of
of your gadget, you know?
By thinking about
stuff in this way, I've--
there's a few features
that I'm building
into some of our upcoming
gadgets, I think,
that are going to be exciting
because I started
thinking about it in this way.
And things I wouldn't have
normally thought to be,
"Oh, that should be social,"
all of sudden, I was like,
"Ah, yeah.
That could be social and
that could be kind of neat."
So at the beginning
of this presentation,
I told you
we would talk about
kind of the opportunities
and challenges
for designing similarities
and differences
and basically talk about
the basic building blocks.
We talked about, you know,
remembering the right audience.
You know, you've still got
your end users out there,
but you've also got this new
site administrator audience
that can really kind of
unlock a lot
of doors for you, potentially.
So you have to be, again,
communicating
your value to them.
And then we talked about
this framework
that can kind of--
starting--
start and get you going.
So at the very least,
I hope I've caused you
to kind of think
about the potential
for reaching out
onto the broader social web.
And at best, maybe
you've started writing code.
But probably not, 'cause Ryan
hasn't talked to you yet.
But I'll hand it
back to him now
and he'll talk about
some of the code implications
for all this.
Cool.
[applause]
Boyd:
Well, thanks, Jonathan
for a much better transition
than I gave you.
But--
[laughs]
OpenSocial--you've heard us
mention it a couple times.
All the gadgets
for Google Friend Connect
are built based on
the OpenSocial standard.
So what are
the OpenSocial APIs?
What is the standard?
Where did it come from?
It came from the idea
that the web is good,
that social is good,
but the social web can be
even better than that.
So where can you
use these APIs?
You can use these APIs
on 25+ social networks
around the world.
Here's a few examples
of the different
social networks
and other sites
which support
the Google Friend Connect
APIs.
And so there are
set networks here
that are things like
traditional social networks
that you go to
to interact with your friends.
There are also sites here
such as LinkedIn
which is more of a business
network that you go to
to establish
business relationships.
And not only are the--these
25+ networks around the world,
but keep in mind
the 5 million web sites
which are also
OpenSocial containers
built on top
of Google Friend Connect.
There are, however,
some technical differences
between what you do
to build a gadget
for a traditional
social network
and what you would do
to build a gadget
for Google Friend Connect.
So I'm going to try to untangle
a little bit of that mess
in the next couple
of slides here.
Maybe it's not a mess,
but anyway,
there's some differences.
So first of all,
the types of data--
with Google Friend Connect,
and with all
OpenSocial containers,
you have some basic
types of data:
profiles and friends,
which have,
in Friend Connect, an I.D.,
a name,
a thumbnail URL,
activities and messages,
and application data
that is specific
to your individual gadget
or application.
You can access all of this
using a couple different ways.
You can access it
using client-side functionality,
things like JavaScript,
or in the new 0.9
implementation of OpenSocial--
which Friend Connect,
as of today, supports.
You can also access it
using OSML and Templates,
which are
some different ways
of developing applications.
All three of these
allow you to do
pretty much the same things,
but the OSML and Templates
allow you to do a little bit
easier development
and make it a little bit
more performant.
And then there's
the server-side access
using REST
and RPC libraries.
So who are the people
that are involved
in your Friend Connect gadgets
or in any OpenSocial gadget?
Basically you have the viewer
and you have the owner.
The viewer--
in traditional
social networks,
the viewer is
the authenticated user
who is using your app.
When--when
they're viewing it,
it's the person
that's using it.
In Google Friend Connect,
the authen--
it's the same thing.
It's the authenticated user
who is viewing
your application.
However, you need to really
remember the anonymous user.
So on those, like,
5 million Google Friend Connect
enabled sites,
they each get, you know,
tons and tons of page views.
And of those
tons and tons of page views,
a lot of them
are actually going to be
logged out users.
You're hoping that--
and, you know,
keeping in mind when
you're designing your gadgets
that the logged in users
are the ones
that are building the data
for the logged out
users to view
and making it interesting
even for the logged out users.
So keep in mind
that the anonymous viewer
is something special here
with Google Friend
Connect gadgets.
Usually
with traditional networks
you don't have to worry
about that too much.
So what information--when
you do have a logged in viewer,
what information
do you have?
You have the I.D.,
ABOUT_ME,
PROFILE_URL,
and THUMBNAIL_URL.
these are the core bits
of information
that you need to use
to make a gadget more social.
The I.D. is simply
a long string of numbers,
the ABOUT_ME is a string
that the user defines
to describe,
like, you know,
in a Twitter sort of
140 characters or less usually
string about
who the person is,
a PROFILE_URL,
which allows you
to link off to their profile,
and a THUMBNAIL_URL,
which is their picture.
In traditional
social networks,
you have some additional
profile data.
So you can see
some listed here.
The darker ones are ones
that aren't currently available
in Google Friend Connect
but are available on some
traditional social networks.
But things like, you know,
SMOKER or DRINKER--
are those things
that you really care about
when you're building
your gadgets?
Probably not,
unless you're trying
to advertise tobacco products
or advertise alcohol.
Those are things
that you just don't care about.
So Friend Connect
does allow you access
to the core bits of data,
which are available
regardless of what site
the user is connected to
for their profile
in Friend Connect.
So in addition
to the viewer,
you have the owner.
In traditional networks,
the owner is the user
who installed the app
that is currently
being viewed.
It's really the same thing
with Friend Connect
but there's a little bit
of a difference here.
The user that installed the app
is really the site.
So in the example of,
you know,
a traditional
social network,
you don't have
an I.D. number
that represents a web site.
In Friend Connect, you do.
So this long number here
is the I.D. for
the chatbotc.com web site.
That's a web site that
has a blog and all on it
from one of our other
developer advocates.
And in addition to that,
you have a PROFILE_URL
for that site.
So if you look
at that site's friends,
it's actually
all the members of the site.
And that's--so that's
some interesting information
that you can get by looking
at the friends of a user,
which in this case
is the web site.
So I'm going to talk to you
about a couple different ways
to use the page context
to build better gadgets.
Just as you wouldn't expect
to see a toilet
sitting out
in the middle of the street,
you also probably
wouldn't expect to see
a Tetris game
on a stock blog
or, you know,
something like that.
So you need
to keep that in mind
as you're building
your gadgets.
You can keep in mind
the content of the page
or the blog.
In this case,
I'm going to show you
some APIs
that exist in Blogger.
So Blogger implements
Google Friend Connect
for many, many blogs
and it's by--
implemented by default
for new blogs.
And Blogger
provides some APIs
for Friend Connect gadgets
which allow you
to get access
to the content
of the posts in the blog
and the content of
the comments in the blog.
Why might you
want to use this?
So imagine this--
you have a blog.
You only have
a couple of followers
and you have some friends
that are also
following your blog.
And your blog has
pictures of your puppy.
Think about
this conversation here.
You know, someone comments,
"Digit is so cute."
If you haven't figured it out,
Digit's my dog.
But some people were commenting,
"Digit is so cute."
John says, "Too girly.
I want a real dog."
And believe me,
people have told me this.
And Jane says,
"Awww, John is nuts."
And then there's a conversation
that goes back and forth
in the blog on the comments.
But what do you
really care about?
In this case, you know,
I have a very popular blog
with, I don't know,
420-some--
420--4 mill--
thousand comments on it.
You really care about
filtering that information
down to what
is interesting to you,
and oftentimes,
what is interesting to you
is the comments that
were made by your friends.
So I care that Jane said,
"Digit is so cute,"
and I care that she said,
"John is nuts."
But I really don't care
that John said
Digit is "too girly"
and he wants "a real dog,"
because I like my dog
perfectly fine.
All right, so here's
some code that does this.
This is using the content
of the comments
and allowing you
to build up a gadget like that.
So I apologize I'm not
going line by line through this,
but basically
what we're doing
is we're looping through
all the comments,
we're looking at the author,
and we're checking to see
if the author is
in my array of friends.
And if the author is
in my array of friends,
then I highlight
that comment.
So now I don't have to look
at all 424,000 comments
on my blog,
I can just look
at the ones I care about.
So--skinning your gadgets.
Jonathan brought this up
a little bit earlier,
but basically
I want to stress the point
that you need
to really fit your gadgets
into the design
and style of the web site--
and not only the design
and style of your web site,
but the design and style of
every single web site out there
that wants
to use your gadget.
Jonathan
gave an example earlier,
but I'll give you
another one,
showing some more pictures
of my dog here.
Number one is a gadget
that is installed by default
when you create a new blog,
and that's
the Followers gadget.
And you can see
how well integrated
it is into the page--
uses the same colors
and the same style.
But number two here is one
of the Friend Connect gadgets
that I just copied
and pasted the code here
using the default colors.
As a gadget developer,
I would hope that I would
allow site administrators
to build gadgets
a little bit better
or to install gadgets
that are built
a little bit better
and integrate well
into their sites.
So we do allow that.
Basically every time
a site administrator
goes and installs a gadget
on a Friend Connect
enabled web site,
they get prompted for a list
of a bunch of things here.
And that list
of a bunch of things
includes preferences
like, you know--
you know,
what should I call this
or what time zone are you in
and things like that.
But it also includes styles.
The styles
that are included
are things like the colors
for various parts
of the gadget.
So you have colors
for the top of the gadget,
the end caps
as we call them,
you have colors
for the borders
and the font text
and all that.
At the time a site administrator
fills this out,
it gen--generates code
that they copy and paste
into their site.
And that code
includes the style preferences
that they've set here.
And in things like Blogger,
these values
are automatically applied
based off of what template
the user has
or the site administrator
has chosen.
They don't have to manually
select the colors.
But as a gadget developer,
how do you
use this information?
Basically there
are a set of properties.
You can read through
the list here.
I'm not going to go
into each of them,
but they are
a set of properties
that represent
the colors and the font faces
and things like that.
And those properties
are all accessible
from within a gadget.
So here's a list
of some more properties,
but again,
you can see these slides
after I/O online.
So after those properties
are defined--
so the site administrator
defines the values
of each of those colors
and they, you know--
becomes passed into the gadget
as properties.
You can then,
as a gadget developer,
get those properties out
by declaring that you're
using the optional feature skins
and then,
in your JavaScript,
going through
and setting the style
on various CSS elements.
So after we do that,
after we make
our gadget skinnable,
then a site administrator
can make the gadget
integrate well
into their site as you see here.
So we've talked about fitting
into the content of the site,
and we've talked about fitting
into the style of the site.
You also need to keep in mind
language,
like Jonathan
alluded to earlier.
So in traditional
social networks,
you go and develop a gadget
and you say,
"I want to make that a gadget
available on MySpace."
And I know MySpace
has a primarily
English-speaking audience,
so you really only care
about the English speakers.
And your gadget
is only in English,
and that's fine with you.
And you're getting the audience
that MySpace gives you.
With Google Friend Connect,
your--
the site administrators
can actually be
all throughout the world,
speaking in all sorts
of different languages,
and audiences in all sorts
of different languages.
So when you go
and submit your gadget
to the Friend Connect
Gadget Gallery--
which I'm going to give you
a preview of
here in a second--
when you go and submit
your gadget to that,
you don't know what the--
what
the site administrators are,
what language they're speaking,
and what the--
the audience that
they're trying to attract is
and what language
they're speaking.
So you want
to keep into account
that information.
There's--localization
is possible
with Google Friend Connect
using the standard
OpenSocial APIs.
There is nothing new here.
This is just standard
vanilla OpenSocial,
so I'm not going to dive
into the details.
But basically
you define message bundles,
and those message bundles
represent the strings
for different languages.
And then in your gadget,
you point
to those message bundles.
But keep that in mind
with Google Friend Connect
specifically.
So now if we rewind
a little bit here
and give you a recap of what
we've talked about here today--
we talked about how
to design applications.
Jonathan talked
in more detail about that.
We also talked about
how to develop code.
We talked about the 5 million
Google Friend Connect sites
out there.
But the key question is:
What's the growth look like?
And we also talked about
the 100,000 new members
of these sites every day.
But how do you
reach your users?
You're not going to go out
and list your application
inside the Yellow Pages.
That would be silly.
I don't know many people
that look to the Yellow Pages
for figuring out
what gadgets to install
on their web sites.
But you can list
your application
in the Google Friend Connect
Gadget Gallery.
So up until now
this has been
a pretty static gallery
that we have manually
added some gadgets to.
There's a couple external
contributed gadgets
but there's something
like ten gadgets in here.
Today we're announcing
that everyone can go out there
and build Google
Friend Connect gadgets
and then have them
listed in the Gadget Gallery.
So you have
those 5 million sites to--
to have as your audience
for your gadget.
There's 100,000 new people
on those sites every day.
You can go to this form,
fill out--
pass your gadget URL
and accept
the terms of service,
and submit your gadget
to be included in a directory
that everyone
as a site administrator can use
to then install your gadget.
Keep in mind,
like, time is a really
valuable thing here.
And right now is really
the best time for you out there
and--develop
Friend Connect Gadgets.
And the reason that is
is there are ten gadgets
or something like that
in the directory
right now.
So you can get out there
and get a little bit
of the first mover advantage
and get a lot of users
right away
if you submit
to the Gadget Gallery soon.
Now there's also
the Blogger Gadget Gallery.
So I mentioned that Blogger
installs Google Friend Connect
on all sites
by default now.
And there are many,
many blogs out there
with Google Friend Connect
on them.
They do have
a separate gallery currently,
but the submission process
is very similar
and you can see
the screenshots
don't really change
that much.
And you can go out there
and submit your gadget
both to the Friend Connect
Gadget Gallery
and the Blogger Gadget Gallery
provided it
fits that audience.
So for more information
about Google Friend Connect,
you can visit this URL.
This URL will allow you
as a site administrator
to get Friend Connect
installed on your web site
super, super quickly
with some copy and paste code.
It will also link off
to our presence
on code.google.com,
which has a lot more
detailed information
for developers
to build gadgets
and also to integrate
Friend Connect
deeply into their site.
And now I'm going to ask
Jonathan to come back up here
and we're gonna take
questions and answer and--
well, we're gonna take questions
and we're gonna give answers.
[Terleski giggles]
You can post your questions
at the Google Moderator page
listed at the bottom here.
And I'm gonna open it up
here in a second.
You're also--feel free
to come up to the microphones
and ask questions
in person.
So I'll leave this up here
for just a second
before I pull into Moderator.
Terleski:
Go ahead.
man: Hi,
I was just wondering--
wondering if you could
talk a little bit about
the intersection between
Web Elements and Friend Connect,
and if there's any.
Boyd:
So one of the elements
that Vic demonstrated
earlier today
was the Conversations
element.
And the Conversations element
is actually built
on top of some of the similar
infrastructure at Google
as Friend Connect.
And, you know, is--
basically allows you
to do that commenting
sort of gadget.
The idea behind Elements
is that you can
just copy and paste
a tiny bit of code
and put that
into your web site
and get up and running,
and that's what you can do
with the Conversations element.
With Friend Connect, there's
one little tiny bit more
you have to do to have a full
Friend Connect implementation,
and that's upload two files
to your web server right now.
But we give you those files
and it's really easy to do.
So, you know,
it basically depends on how--
how much work
you're planning on doing.
If you can upload
two files to your server,
then you can up--
then you can go
for the full
Friend Connect installation,
and that allows you
to have some more
social conversations and all
on your site
and allow the users
to interact back and forth,
and you can install
other Friend Connect gadgets.
But if you're looking for just
that commenting sort of gadget
then the element that Vic
talked about at the keynote
works fine for you.
man: Can I ask
is there any impact
that these Google Gadgets--
if they're proliferated
to other sites--
will have
on the Google ranking
for the page for which
they're referenced to?
Boyd:
Absolutely none.
I mean, the--the gadgets
have nothing to do
with our web search
ranking algorithms.
All right, let's go
to the question here.
"What Android release
"will these types
of Google Gadgets land on?
"Will they be rendered
via webkit
"on the Android home screen?
"Are there additional design/
development considerations
that come into play
for Android?"
I can't really speak to that.
Right now
Google Friend Connect
is a product
that's targeted at web sites
and to allow you to easily
have that social interaction
on your web site.
We don't have--or I don't
have any information
on how this
would impact Android.
Terleski:
Yeah, I think the...
again, the context is--
is for web sites.
And so I think kind of
how you would end up
seeing them on Android,
right,
is you'd be launching your
browser and going to a web site
and that would render,
and you would be interacting
with the gadget
just like you would if
you were on a desktop machine.
Again, these gadgets
are kind of about
letting site owners
imbue their sites
with social functionality,
not so much, you know,
breaking out gadgets
as a type of
a dashboard-y type thing.
Boyd: But I can give you
a little bit of a plug
for a session
I'm doing tomorrow
on using OpenSocial
on mobile devices,
and that dives into more
using the raw APIs
of OpenSocial--
not Friend Connect,
but the raw APIs
of OpenSocial
to make mobile apps
a little bit more
interactive and social.
woman:
Hi, I was wondering--
Boyd: Oh, actually, Sami--
Sami here
is the tech lead
for Google Friend Connect,
so welcome, everyone,
to Sami.
[applause]
Terleski: [laughs]
Whose mic do you want?
Boyd:
You can just--
Shalabi: One additional
point about mobile,
I mean, we do have
a restful API to the service
which means you can
still build mobile apps
that leverage
that restful API.
Boyd:
Thanks, Sami.
[chuckles]
woman: So I was wondering
if there is any infrastructure
in which...
the gadgets can communicate
among each other,
like a selection in a gadget
would control the content
in another gadget
or something similar.
So we don't currently have
cross-gadget communication
built into
Google Friend Connect.
However, a lot of gadgets
with OpenSocial
do have back-end servers.
So, you know,
some of the apps
that I'll show in
the mobile session or whatever--
I use App Engine
as a back end.
And there are a lot of different
OpenSocial gadgets
which would do that.
So you could easily,
in a gadget,
ping your back-end server
with some information
and have it--that affect
another gadget.
But right now,
primarily
the way security works
between IFRAMEs--
there is no way to communicate
between the gadgets.
woman: Can I ask another
short question?
Boyd:
Sure.
woman: So I--I didn't get,
I think, the first part.
So the Google Friend Connect--
does it have, like,
the whole infrastructure
where you place
the gadget that--
does it remember those things
or is it just--
it's not that much?
It's like if you
place two gadgets
somewhere, I don't--
on a web site,
does it somehow
store that configuration?
Or is it
like a portal in a way?
Or is it not so much?
Boyd:
So...
there's no,
like, templates defined
that say, like, you know,
"When you install one gadget,
install these three others
with it."
There's nothing like that.
From a site administrator's
viewpoint,
they're choosing individually
what gadgets to install.
So you could easily
make a web site
that is kind of like a portal
using Google Friend Connect
gadgets.
But you as a site administrator
right now
would be choosing what gadgets
to embed on that page.
There might be some,
you know,
ways to--
to do it differently
and have your users
choose it,
but that's not
available by default.
woman:
Okay, thanks.
Terleski: It might have been
good for us to show
an actual snippet up here
of what it looks like,
what the site
administrator's grabbing.
But they're essentially
grabbing, you know,
what amounts to an IFRAME
and dropping it on their site.
To give you some idea of--
man:
About the Canvas view,
that works really awesome
on iGoogle
so that we can design
things that then float out.
But it seems that
we have to design our own--
like we can't use
the Google Gadget container
on other sites, 'cause
it's stuck in an IFRAME,
so it can't Canvas out.
Am I just wrong about that,
or is there a simple way to...
Boyd: So one of those--
one of those two files
that you upload
that I was referring to in--
in the difference between
the Conversation element
and Google Friend Connect--
one of the two files with
Friend Connect that you upload
is a Canvas page,
which is like canvas.html.
By default
it's configured with a style
that, you know,
is just a default style.
But you can go in
as a site administrator
and customize
the style of that page.
And then anytime you go
to the Canvas view
on a gadget
that's on your site,
it redirects over
to that page
and then, you know,
brings the gadget
into full size there.
man: I see,
so if someone else
installs your gadget
on their site,
and you're using
that feature...
Boyd: If someone else installs
your gadget on their site,
it will redirect
over to their Canvas page
with the Gadget
at full size.
Then they can configure
how that Canvas page looks.
If you come up afterwards,
I can give you a demonstration
of that too.
Terleski: I think we're
being told to wrap it up.
Boyd: All right.
We're actually about--being--
Terleski: So if you
have questions, come on up.
And we can chat some more.
Boyd: Yep.
[applause]